if you want to be a professional Android
developer it's critical to know how many
people use your app and how they use it
for that you need google analytics take
this course created by Udacity in
collaboration with Google to learn how
to interpret google analytics into your
android app packed with practical health
and code samples the course shows just
how easy it is to find out where in the
world people use your app which
activities they use and even how many
people are using the app right now
you'll discover that it takes only a few
lines of code to track your users
locations languages events shopping
behavior and much more you'll also learn
how to use Google tag manager to update
your app without needing to redeploy the
apk and to manage all your Google
Analytics code tags get started now at
Udacity com / google